I think that too many times YouTube is
substituting for a babysitter or
substituting for parenting or or your
neighbors I think that the core the
family is the nuclear building block of
society right but you should know your
community as well right that's one of
the reasons I love coming into an office
I know the people I work with I know
what's going on with their life I think
we could all be better about knowing
what the other people on our street or
in our building I mean you're right not
everyone can move to a farm but you
could know your neighbor if you could
know them better you could build a
relationship with them especially if
they are the people living next door to
you right it's one thing to follow an an
influencer because maybe you're
interested in something they're working
on or whatever else but you can't let
those parasocial bonds uh replace the
Real Life Connections you can have with
people